is providing opportunity for all
including african-americans
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
members of the
congress i have the great and personal
pleasure
the high
privilege
and the distinct
honor
of presenting to you
the president
of the united states
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
mr speaker
mr president
members of the congress my fellow
americans
on this hill which was my home
i am stirred by old friendships
though
total agreement between the executive
and the
congress
is impossible
total respect
is important
i am proud to be among my colleagues of
the congress
whose legacy to their trust
is their loyalty to their nation
i'm not unaware
of the inner emotions
of the new members of this body tonight
28 years ago i felt as you do now
you will soon learn that you are among
men
whose first love is their country
men
who try each day
to do
as best they can
what they believe is right
we are entering the third century
of the pursuit of american union
200 years ago in 1765
nine assembled colonies
first joined together
to demand freedom from arbitrary power
for the first century
we struggled
to hold together the first continental
union
of democracy in the history of man
one hundred years ago
in 1865
following a terrible test of blood and
fire
the compact of union was finally sealed
for a second century
we labored to establish a unity of
purpose and interest
among the many groups which make up the
american community
that struggle has often
brought pain
and balance
it is not yet over
but we have achieved a unity of interest
among our people
that is unmatched
in the history of freedom
and so tonight
now in 1965
we begin a new quest
for union
we seek the unity of man with the world
that he has built
with the knowledge that can save or
destroy him
with the cities which can stimulate or
stifle him
with the wealth in the machines which
can enrich
or diminish his spirit
we seek to establish a harmony
between man and society
which will allow each of us
to enlarge the meaning of his life
and all of us
to elevate the quality
of our civilization
this is the search
that we begin tonight
but the unity we seek cannot realize its
full promise
in isolation
for
today
the state of the union
depends in large measure
upon the state of the world
our concern and interest
compassion and vigilance
extend to every corner
of a dwindling planet
yet it is not merely our concern
but the concern of all free men
we will not and we should not
assume that it is the task of americans
alone
to settle all the conflicts
of a torn and troubled world
let the foes of freedom take no comfort
from this
for in concert with other nations
we shall help men defend their freedom
[Applause]
our first aim remains the safety
and the well-being of our own country
we are prepared to live as good
neighbors with all
but we cannot be indifferent to acts
designed to injure our interests
or our citizens
or our establishments abroad
the community of nations
[Applause]
the community of nations requires mutual
respect
we shall extend it
and we shall expect it
[Applause]
in our relations with the world we shall
follow the
example of andrew jackson
who said
i intend to ask for nothing
that is not clearly
right and to submit
to nothing that is wrong
[Applause]
and he promised that the honor of my
country
shall never be stained by an apology
from me
for the statement of truth
or for the performance of duty
[Applause]
that was this nation's policy in the
1830s and that is this nation policy in
the 1960s
[Applause]
our own
freedom and growth have never been
the final goal of the american dream
we were never meant to be
an oasis
of liberty and abundance
in a worldwide desert of disappointed
dreams
our nation was created to
help
strike away the chains of ignorance and
misery and tyranny
wherever they keep man
less than god
means him to be
we're moving toward that destiny never
more rapidly
than we've moved in the last four years
in this period we have built a military
power strong enough
to meet any threat
and destroy any adversary
and that superiority will continue to
grow
so long
as this office is mine
and you sit on capitol hill
[Applause]
in this period
no
new nation
has become communist
and the unity of the communist empire
has begun to crumble
in this period we have resolved in
friendship our disputes with our
neighbors of the hemisphere
and joined in an alliance for progress
toward economic growth and political
democracy
in this period we have taken more steps
toward peace
including the test ban treaty
and at any time since the cold war began
in this period we have relentlessly
pursued our advances toward the conquest
of space
most important of all in this period
the united has emerged into the fullness
of its self-confidence
and purpose
no longer
are we called upon to get america moving
we are moving
no longer do we doubt
our strength
our resolution
we are strong
and we have proven
our resolve
[Music]
[Applause]
no longer can anyone wonder whether
we're in the grip of historical decay
we know that history is ours to make and
if there is great danger
there is now also
the excitement
of great expectations
yet we still live in a troubled and
perilous world
there is no longer a single threat
there are many
they differ in intensity
and in danger
they require different attitudes
and different answers
with the soviet union
we seek peaceful understanding
that can lessen
the danger to freedom
last fall i asked the american people
to choose that course
i will carry forward their command
[Applause]
if we are to live together in peace
we must come to know each other better
i am sure that the american people
would welcome a chance to listen to the
soviet leaders
on our television
as i would like
the soviet people
to hear our leaders
on theirs
[Applause]
i hope the new soviet leaders can visit
america
so they can learn about our country at
firsthand
in eastern europe
restless nations
are slowly beginning to assert their
identity
your government
assisted by the leaders in american
labor and business
is now exploring ways
to increase
peaceful trade
with these countries
and with the soviet union
i will report our conclusions
to the congress
in asia
communism wears a more aggressive face
we see that in vietnam
why are we there
we are there first
because a friendly nation
has asked us for help
against the communist aggression
ten years ago
our president pledged our health
three presidents
have supported that pledge
and we will not break it now
[Applause]
second
our own security is tied to the peace of
asia
twice in one generation
we have had to fight
against aggression
in the far east
to
ignore aggression now
would only increase the danger
of a much larger war
our goal is
peace in southeast asia
that will come only when aggressors
leave their neighbors in peace
what is at stake
is the cause of freedom
and in that cause
america will never be found wanting
but communism is not the only source of
trouble and unrest their older and
deeper sources
in the misery of nations and in man's
irrepressible ambition
for liberty and a better life
with the free republics of latin america
i have always felt and
my country has always felt
very special ties of interest and
affection
it will be the purpose
of my administration
to strengthen these ties
together we share and shape the destiny
of the new world
and in the coming year i hope to pay a
visit to latin america
and i will steadily enlarge our
commitment
to the alliance for progress
as the instrument of our war
against poverty and injustice in this
hemisphere
[Applause]
in the atlantic community we continue to
pursue our goal of 20 years
a europe that's growing in strength
unity
and cooperation with america
a great unfinished task is the
reunification of germany through
self-determination
this european policy is not based on
any abstract design
it is based on the realities of common
interests and common values
common dangers and common expectations
these realities
will continue
to have their way
and in our
especially i think in our expanding
trade
and especially in our
common defense
free americans have shaped the policy of
the united states
and
because
we know these realities
those policies have been
and will be
in the interests of europe
free europeans must shape the course of
europe
and for the same reasons
that course has been
and will be
in our
interest
and in the interest of freedom
i found this truth confirmed in my talks
with european leaders in the last year
i hope to
repay these visits
to some of our friends in europe
this year
[Applause]
in africa and asia we are witnessing the
turbulent unfolding
of new nations and continents
we welcome them to the society of
nations
we are committed to help those
seeking to
strengthen their own independence
and to work
most closely
with those governments dedicated
to the welfare of all of their people
we seek not fidelity to an iron faith
but a diversity of belief as varied as
man himself
we seek not to extend the power of
america
but the progress of humanity
we seek not to dominate others
but to
strengthen
the freedom of all people
i will seek new ways to use our
knowledge
to help deal with the explosion
in world population
and the growing scarcity
in world resources
[Applause]
[Applause]
finally we renew our commitment to the
continued growth and the effectiveness
of the united nations
[Applause]
the frustrations of the united nation
are
a product of the world that we live in
and not of the institution which gives
them voice
it is far better to throw these
differences open
to the assembly of nations
than to permit them to fester
in silent danger
these are some of the goals of the
american nation in the world in which we
live
for ourselves we seek neither praise nor
blame
neither gratitude
nor obedience
we seek peace
we seek freedom
we seek to
enrich the life of man
for that is the world in which
we will
flourish and that is the world that we
mean
for all men to ultimately have
[Applause]
world affairs will continue to call upon
our energy and our courage
but today we can turn increased
attention to the character of american
life
we're in the midst of the greatest
upward surge of economic well-being in
the history of any nation
our flourishing progress has been marked
by price stability that's unequaled in
the world
our balance of payments deficit has
declined
and the soundness of our dollar is
unquestioned
i pledge to keep it that way
[Applause]
and i urge business and labor to
cooperate to that end
[Applause]
we work for two centuries to climb this
peak of prosperity
but we're only at the beginning of the
road
to the great society
ahead now is a summit
where freedom from the wants of the body
can help fulfill
the needs of the spirit
we built this nation
to serve its people
we want to grow
and build
and create
but we want progress to be the servant
and not the master of man
we do not intend to live in the midst of
abundance
isolated from neighbors and nature
confined by blighted cities and bleak
suburbs
stunted by a poverty of learning
and an emptiness of leisure
the great society asked not how much
but how good
[Applause]
not only how to create wealth
but how to use it
not only how fast
we're going
but where we're headed
it proposes as the first test for a
nation
the quality of its people
this kind of society will not
flower spontaneously
from swelling riches
and surging power
it will not be the gift of government to
the creation of presidents
it will require of every american for
many generations
both faith in the destination and the
fortitude
to make the journey
and like freedom itself
it will always be challenge
and not fulfillment
and tonight
we accept that challenge
[Applause]
i propose that we begin a program in
education to ensure
every american child
the fullest development of his mind and
skills
i propose that we begin a massive attack
on crippling and killing diseases
[Applause]
i propose that we launch a national
effort
to make the american city
a better and a more stimulating place to
live
propose that we
increase the beauty of america
and end the poisoning
of
our rivers
and the air that we breathe
i propose that we carry out a new
program to develop regions of our
country that are now suffering from
distress and depression
i propose that we make new efforts
to control
and prevent crime
and delinquency
i propose that we eliminate every
remaining obstacle
to the right
and the opportunity
to vote
[Applause]
i propose that we honor and support the
achievements of thought
and the creations of art
[Applause]
i propose that we make an all-out
campaign
against waste
and inefficiency
[Applause]
our basic task is threefold
first to keep our economy growing
to open
for all americans the opportunity that
is now enjoyed
by most americans
and to improve the
quality of life
for all
in the next six weeks i will submit
special messages
with detailed proposals for national
action
in each of these areas
tonight i would like just briefly to
explain some of my major recommendations
in the three main areas
of national need
first
we must keep our nation prosperous
we seek full employment opportunity
for every american citizen
[Applause]
i will present a budget designed to move
the economy forward
more money will be left in the hands of
the consumer
by a substantial cut in excise taxes
[Applause]
we will continue
along the path toward a balanced budget
in a balanced economy
[Applause]
i confidently predict what every
economic sign
tells us tonight
the continued flourishing
of the american economy
but we must remember
that fear of a recession
can contribute to the fact
of a recession
the knowledge that our government will
and can move swiftly
will strengthen the confidence
of investors
and business
congress can reinforce this confidence
by
ensuring that its procedures
permit rapid action on temporary income
tax cuts
and special funds for job creating
public programs
should be made available for immediate
use
if recession threatens
our continued prosperity demands
continued price stability
business labor and the consumer all have
a high stake in keeping wages and prices
within the framework of the guideposts
that have already served the nation so
well
finding new markets abroad for our goods
depends on the initiative of american
business
but we stand ready with credit and other
help
to assist the flow of trade
which will benefit the entire nation
our economy owes much to the efficiency
of our farmers
we must continue to assure them the
opportunity
to earn a fair reward
i have instructed the secretary of
agriculture
to lead a major effort
to find new approaches
to reduce the heavy cost
of our farm programs
and to direct more of our effort
to the small farmer
who needs the help the most
[Applause]
we can help
ensure
continued prosperity
through a regional recovery program to
assist the development of stricken areas
left behind by our national progress
further efforts to provide our workers
with the skills demanded
by modern technology
for the laboring man as an indispensable
force
in the american system the extension of
the minimum wage
to more than two million unprotected
workers
the improvement and the modernization
of the unemployment compensation system
and as pledged in our 1960
and 1964 democratic platforms
i will propose to congress
changes in the taft-hartley act
including section 14b
i will do so hoping to
reduce the conflicts
that for several years have divided
americans
in various states of our union
in a country that spans a continent
modern transportation is vital to
continued growth
i will recommend heavier reliance on
competition in transportation
and a new policy
for our merchant marine
[Applause]
i will ask for funds to study high-speed
rail transportation between urban
centers
we will begin with test projects between
washington and boston
on high-speed trains
passengers could travel this distance in
less than four hours
second we must open opportunity to all
our people
most americans
enjoy a good life
but far too many
are still trapped in poverty and
idleness
and fear
let a just nation throw open to them
the city of promise
to the elderly
by providing hospital care
under social security and by raising
benefit payments to those struggling to
maintain the dignity of their later
years
to the poor and the unfortunate through
doubling
the war against poverty this year
[Applause]
to negro americans
through enforcement of the civil rights
law
and elimination of barriers to the right
to vote
[Applause]
to those in other lands that are seeking
the promise of america through an
immigration law based on the work a man
can do
and not where he was born
or how he spells his name
[Applause]
our third goal is to improve the quality
of american life
we begin with learning
every child must have the best education
that this nation can provide
[Applause]
thomas jefferson said that no nation can
be both ignorant and free
today
no nation can be both ignorant and great
in addition to our existing programs i
will recommend a new program for schools
and students
with a first-year authorization of one
billion five hundred million dollars
[Applause]
it will help at every stage along the
road to learning
for the preschool years we will help
needy children
become aware of the excitement of
learning
for the primary and secondary school
years
we will aid public schools serving
low-income families
and assist students
in both public and private schools
[Applause]
for the college years we'll provide
scholarships
to high school students of the greatest
promise
and the greatest need
and we will guarantee low entries loans
to students continuing
their college studies
[Applause]
new
laboratories and centers
will help our schools
help them lift their standards of
excellence
and explore new methods of teaching
these centers will provide special
training for those who need and those
who deserve special treatment
greatness requires not only an educated
people
but a healthy people
our goal is to match the achievements of
our medicine
to the afflictions of our people
we already carry on a large program in
this country for research
and health
in addition
regional medical centers can provide the
most advanced diagnosis and treatment
for heart disease
and cancer and stroke and other major
diseases
new support for medical and dental
education
will provide the trained people
to apply our knowledge
community centers can help the mentally
ill and improve health care for
school-aged children
from poor families
including services for the mentally
[ __ ]
and educated and healthy people
require surroundings in harmony
with their hosts
in our urban areas
the central problem today is to protect
and restore man's satisfaction in
belonging to a community where he can
find security and significance
the first step is to break old patterns
to begin to think and work and plan for
the development of the entire
metropolitan areas
we will take this step with new programs
of help for the basic community
facilities
and for neighborhood centers of health
and recreation
new and existing programs will be open
to those cities which work together to
develop unified long-range policies for
metropolitan areas
we must also make some very important
changes in our housing program
if we are to pursue these same basic
goals
so a department of housing and urban
development
will be needed to spearhead this effort
in our cities
every citizen has the right to feel
secure
in his home
and on the streets of his community
[Applause]
to help control crime we will recommend
program
to train local law enforcement officers
to put the best techniques of modern
science
at their disposal
to discover the causes of crime
and better ways to prevent it
i will soon assemble a panel of
outstanding experts of this nation
to search out answers to the national
problem
of crime
and delinquency and i welcome the
recommendations and the constructive
efforts of the congress
for
over three centuries
the beauty of america
has sustained our spirit and has
enlarged our vision
we must act now
to protect this heritage
in a fruitful new partnership with the
states and the cities the next decade
should be a conservation milestone
we must make a massive effort
to save the countryside
and to establish as a green legacy for
tomorrow
more large and small parks
more seashores and open spaces
and have been created during any other
period in our national history
[Applause]
a new and substantial effort must be
made to landscape highways
to provide places of relaxation and
recreation
wherever our roads run
within our cities imaginative programs
are needed
to landscape streets and to transform
open areas
into places of beauty and recreation
we will seek legal power
to prevent pollution of our air and
water before it happens
[Applause]
we will step up our effort to control
harmful wastes
giving first priority to the cleanup of
our most contaminated rivers
we will increase research
to learn much more
about the control of pollution
we hope to make the potomac
a model of beauty here in the capital
[Applause]
[Applause]
and preserve unspoiled stretches
of some of our waterways
with a wild riversville
more ideas for a beautiful america will
emerge from a white house conference on
national beauty
which i will soon call
we must also recognize and encourage
those
who can be pathfinders
for the nation's imagination and
understanding
to help promote
and honor creative achievements
i will propose a national foundation on
the arts
[Applause]
to develop knowledge which will enrich
our lives and ensure our progress
i will recommend programs to encourage
basic science
particularly in the universities
and to bring close of the day
when the oceans will supply
our growing need
for fresh water
[Applause]
for government to serve these goals it
must be modern in structure efficient in
action
and ready for any emergency
i am
busy currently reviewing the structure
of the entire executive branch of this
government
i hope to reshape it
and to reorganize it
to meet more effectively the task of the
20th century
wherever waste is found
i will eliminate it
last year we saved almost
three billion five hundred million
dollars
by eliminating waste in the national
government
and i intend to do better this year
[Applause]
and very soon i will report to you
on our progress
and on new economies that your
government plans to make
even the best of government
is subject to the worst of hazards
i will propose laws to ensure the
necessary continuity of leadership
should the president become disabled or
die
in addition i will propose reforms in
the electoral college
leaving undisturbed
the vote by states
but making sure that no elector
can substitute his will
for that of the people
[Applause]
last year in a sad moment
i came here and i spoke to you
after 33 years of public service
practically all of them here on this
hill
this year
i speak after one year
as president of the united states
many of you in this chamber are among my
oldest friends
we have shared many
happy moments and many hours of work
and we've watched many presidents
together
yet
only in the white house
can you
finally
know the full weight
of this office
the greatest burden is not running the
huge operations of government
or meeting daily troubles large and
small
are
even working with the congress
a president's hardest task
is not to do what is right
but to know what is right
yet the presidency brings no special
gift of prophecy
or foresight
you take an oath
you step into an office
and you must then help guide a great
democracy
the answer was waiting for me in the
land where i was born
it was once
barren land
the angular hills were covered with
scrub cedar
and a few large live oaks
little would grow in that harsh
caliche soil
of my country
and each spring the pertinalis river
would flood our valley
but men came and they worked and they
endured and they built
and tonight that country is abundant
abundant with fruit and cattle and goats
and sheep
and there are pleasant homes and lakes
and the floods are gone
why did men come to that once forbidding
land
well they were restless of course
and they had to be moving on
but there was more than that
there was a dream
a dream of a place
where a free man
could build for himself
and raise his children
to a better life
a dream of a continent
to be conquered
a world to be one
a nation
to be made
remembering this
i knew the answer
a president does not shape a new and
personal vision of america
he collects it from the scattered hopes
of the american past
it existed when the first settlers
saw the coast of a new world
and when the first pioneers
moved westward
it has guided us
every step of the way
it sustains
every president
but it is also
your
inheritance
and it belongs equally
to all the people
that we all serve
it must be interpreted in you by each
generation for its own needs
as i have tried in part to do tonight
it shall lead us as we enter the third
century
of the search
for a more perfect union
this then
is the state of the union
free
and restless
growing
and full of hope
so it was
in the beginning
so it shall always be
while
god is willing
and we are strong enough
to keep the faith
[Applause]
[Applause]
you